the division in America is clear right
on Donald Trump's doorstep
a protest movement painting an uneasy
portrait he's struggling to erase he
declared an unexpected victory with
unemployment dropping to 13.3%
surprising forecasters and he couldn't
resist bringing George Floyd's name into
it
hopefully George is looking down right
now and saying this is a great thing
that's happening for our country there's
a great day for him it's a great day for
everybody this is a great day for
everybody this is a great great day in
terms of equality it's really what our
Constitution requires and it's what our
country is all about less than 24 hours
after his Memorial those words sparked
outrage in an increasingly fortified
Washington his political rival Joe Biden
insists he's the man to lead the economy
and soothe America's racial divisions
but his words are also being picked
apart they're probably anywhere from 10
to 15 percent the people out there
they're just not very good people that
will sit uncomfortably with many
Americans and so will this two offices
in Buffalo shoving a 75 year old
protester he sustained a head injury
they were suspended their entire
emergency response unit resigned in
support of them their union claiming
they were only executing orders when I
saw the video I got sick to my stomach
I think the city should pursue firing
and I think the district attorney should
look at the situation for possible
criminal charges this has been a week
marked by discord and mourning but
little resolution about how to solve two
things plaguing America racism and
police violence but now here in
Minneapolis there are some signs of
change a ban on chokehold
police officers will be required to
report and intervene if they see an
unauthorized use of force by another
officer in a place that looks
apocalyptic in places that will be seen
as progress
Cordelia Lynch Sky News Minneapolis